good day everyone warmly welcome to this
press conference where we will soon
present this very ascetic spank prize in
economic sciences in memory of Alfred
Nobel for 2013 we keep to our pretty old
tradition to start and Swedish and then
continue in English and then when there
are questions you can post them in
either language yo yo here this
afternoon mark you're a standard
security at are evacuating scoffs
Academy were made had to hear get high a
professor in paterson smooth foreign the
econom economy please committee an oak
professor torsten passion smelly adamu
Ecomedia whatever enstrom a is it the
professor Pelham Bay auxilia da mood
economy please committee on Adamski's
rock spirit amir uma preset han laron or
its economy please Hamlin third sable
here come the evidence cops academy in
hobbies luta to Dallas very serious
banks prissy economics cretins coop tell
Alfred Nobel's min or photos and
threaten till professor Eugene former
the University of Chicago us all oak
professor Lars Peter Hanson with
University of Chicago you saw Oh
professor Robert Shiller the yale
university new haven you saw oh please
motivating a loser Federer's impedes
canales of till gongs please sir this
year's prize in economic sciences is
about predictions the royal swedish
academy of sciences has decided to vote
this very sleek spanked prize in
economic sciences in memory of alfred
nobel 2013 to professor Eugene fama from
University of Chicago you saw use em
professor Lars Peter Hansen from
University of Chicago you say and
professor Robert Shiller from yale
university new haven USA and the Cadmus
citation runs for their
empirical analysis of asset prices
professor crocell will now give us a
short summary in English please thank
you Stefan so this year's prize in
economic sciences or nurse empirical
findings about the price movements of
assets such as stocks and bonds in the
1960s and 70s Eugene fama established
that prices are extremely hard to
predict over shorter horizons he also
demonstrated how new information such as
dividend announcements gets incorporated
very quickly into prices in sharp
contrast in the early 1980s Robert
Shiller discovered significant
predictability over longer horizons when
asset prices are high relative to
dividends they tend to be followed by
low returns over the following three to
seven years how should these
predictability findings be interpreted
Lars Hanson ski contribution was to
develop and apply a new statistical
method the generalized method of moments
to evaluate the standard theory asset
pricing he found that the standard
theory which views investors as rational
had great trouble explaining the data
this gave rise to intense research
efforts the approach with which Hansen
and others pursuit is based on time
varying dividend risk and risk aversion
with this approach low prices can be
explained by high perceived risk and the
subsequent high return is then a
compensation for the risk another
approach where Robert Shiller has been a
pioneer can be found in a new area of
behavioral finance the main idea here is
that investors forecast need not be
perfectly rational periods of low prices
then represent periods of excessive
pessimism so the current understanding
of asset prices relies in part on
rational investors and their concerns
about risk and in part on psychology and
behave
violence farmers Hansen's and Sheila's
research not only radically changed the
views among researchers but also
influenced market practice in many ways
okay thank you professor Chris l and now
turn to Professor Stromberg to give a
more detailed presentation so this
year's price is about prices and
financial markets and financial market
prices are absolutely crucial to the
economy because the prices of assets
like stocks bonds and real estate they
give important signals to firms in what
they should be investing in they give
signals to households and what they
should save in and they also affect how
much risk is taking investments and
savings in the economy so because of
this importance of asset prices it's
very important to understand how well
these financial markets work in pricing
acids now if we look over history we
often see very large fluctuations an
asset prices up and down and one example
could be you know during the late 90s we
saw technology stocks reach record highs
and then if you laterz dramatic drops in
these prices so it's very important to
understand whether these fluctuations
and prices are a sign of something not
working correctly in in financial
markets because to the extent these
fluctuations are due to miss pricing
they could have large negative effects
on the economy now when you want to
understand how well asset prices work
and predictability ie whether you can
foresee how future prices in financial
markets going to evolve become a central
issue and the picture you see here may
look like a stock price index but as a
matter of fact is a completely random
series is what happens if you flip a
coin a number of times and you count the
number of tails minus the comp number of
heads so this is a series that you may
see some patterns in but it's completely
random series now it turns out that if
financial markets work well we would
actually expect stock prices for example
financial market prices to exhibit
exactly the same random behavior
year the reason for this is that a
financial markets work well then all the
new information about you know that's
relevant for the future value of these
assets should be immediately
incorporated than the price so that you
know you really can't make any money for
example from reading in the newspaper in
the morning that profits of this
particular firm is going to be higher in
the future because the price will
already have adjusted and whatever
variation we see that's left is going to
be around so there's one exception to
that however which has to do with
compensation for risk so assets that are
more risky for investors they're going
to be less likely or they are less
willing to invest in those assets and to
induce investors to do that they need to
get a higher return for more risky
assets so we would expect stocks have a
higher return because their risk here
compared to bonds or government bonds
that are safer so all of these issues
these show predictability and whether
that's consistent with financial markets
working is central to these laureates
work and they looked at predictability
in the short run they looked at
predictability of the longer run partly
getting somewhat different results as
you've heard and the important of this
research is that it really greatly
improved our understanding of how
financial markets work you know when
market seemed to work well when they
seemed to work less well if we start
with Eugene fama he's really the
founding father of this literature he
started doing research in the 1960s on
predictability and his focus was on the
very short term let's say days or weeks
whether you can predict how stock prices
are going to do in the future based on
historical stock price patterns and as
we said earlier you know if markets work
well historical prices really shouldn't
have much to say about how prices are
going to move in the future and that's
indeed what Jean farmers early studies
found he also helped developed a new
method to focus on how quickly does new
information get incorporated in prices
so if markets work well we would expect
new information that's relevant about
the stock to be more or less instantly
in court
rather than the price and this picture
here shows you an example of such a
study they're called events studies and
this particular event study looks at how
do stock prices react when firms
announced that they're going to increase
their future dividend okay so that's
something good that should make this
talk more valuable and as you see the
0ther is the day when this announcement
is made and what this event studies by
and large have shown is that you see a
pretty much instant adjustment of stock
prices to this information on average
okay so this is a chart of many
thousands of such announcement but on
average you see that you know you
basically see no particular trend before
you see a rapid adjustment and no
particular trend after so and this
research that in pharma pioneered was
really incredibly influential and
surprising to people at the time and but
by the after these studies and let's say
by the mid to late 70s was pretty much
consensus among economists that you know
market seemed to work well there was not
much predictability in prices now the
person who sort of changed the views for
a lot of people here in this respect was
Robert Shiller now unlike Jean Pharma
Robert Shiller looked at predictability
over longer horizons let's say years or
even decades and the first revolutionary
finding at the time he found was that it
looked like financial market prices
let's say stock prices were much more
volatile they move much more than the
underlying dividends did and this was a
pricing because actually the if markets
work well we would probably expect the
opposite we would expect dividends and
earnings to move around much more than
stock prices they then went on together
with co-authors to show that this high
movement in stock price which basically
what that means is that sometimes stocks
become very expensive compared to the
underlying dividends and sometimes talks
become cheaper compared to underlying
dividends and this actually implied that
you could predict future movements in
stock prices so this picture here shows
you a measure
how quote-unquote cheap or expensive
stocks are it's basically taking the
dividends of the stock more US stock
market and divide that by the value of
the US stock market so when this is high
when the dividends / prices are high
rock stocks and Sampson's are relatively
cheap while other periods you know we
see the late 2000s during the technology
boom dividend / price is very low
because prices of stocks are you know
very high now if you take this measure
dividend over price and then you see
does that say anything about how stock
markets will behave in the you know next
few years it turns out it has a very
strong predictability pattern here so in
periods when stocks seem relatively
cheap the dividend divided by price is
high you see in this this line is sort
of the seven year returns on the stock
market following this particular year
you see much higher returns in the stock
market following periods for dividends
over price is high and vice versa okay
so this was you know a very important
finding it changed the views on
predictability of a lot of people the
question is how should you interpret
this now if you look at farmers findings
of not no predictability in the short
term they were more easy to interpret
that these long term predictability
pattern because of the long term prices
could be predictable not because there's
something wrong with them but actually
because they reflect changes in how much
compensation investors need for risk so
it could for example be that when stocks
are cheap and you see subsequent high
returns that Spears when people are not
very interested in investing in stocks
they're very averse to the risk in the
stock market and because of that reason
you see a high return so there was a we
have a standard model for this is called
the consumption cap em that basically
predicts this pattern in in prices
however these models are very hard to
test because they are hard to solve they
often rely in order to solve them you
need to make very specific assumptions
about how you know the model works
and the relationships you get out of
these models are very nonlinear and
complex so it's hard to test them and
this is where our third laureate Lars
Hanson comes in he first developed a
very powerful statistical method which
enabled you to test these types of
models using very general assumptions
this methodology which is called GMM or
generalized method the moments turned
out not to be to be important not only
for asset price research but actually
all across economics and has become one
of the most widely used empirical
methods to study all sorts of things and
economics he then went on to take his
new theory and test this standard model
of how expected returns should move over
time and he basically showed that this
model I talked about this or a rational
model of predictability which says that
predictability is driven by people
changes in people's willingness to take
risks that could not explain or give
rise to enough fluctuations and prices
to be consistent with the theory so
basically this this first test actually
rejected this standard theory of that
that was based on well-functioning asset
markets now together the research of
these three lawyers had an enormous
impact on the way we think about
research in an academic research on
Finance and you know the the findings on
these laureates obviously a lot of work
went into try to figure out you know is
this due to Marcus not working or are we
missing something in our models and
they're basically two parallel and often
complementary research approaches that
have emerged after this one which was
pioneered by Robert Shiller is called
behavioral finance and that tries to
build off the premise that these large
fluctuations and this predictability was
in prices is because investors you know
irrationally for example by over
optimism or pessimism price you know
have the wrong price of assets now for
that to work you also need an additional
ingredient which is that there are some
sophisticated investors that for some
reason or the other can set prices right
they can benefit
from the mistake of these irrational
investors so a lot of this research has
been used to kind of document frictions
to financial markets which makes it hard
for sophisticated investors at prices
right the other track has been to
develop you know start with with markets
that function but instead take the
standard very simple standard model that
Hanson rejected and try to make it more
realistic try to incorporate more
realistic preferences more realistic
market environments and by now we
actually have some models of investor
preference that seem much more
consistent with a with the results that
she'll are found so together actually as
I said these these two approaches are
not are not exclusive and they
complement each other and I think
current this current state of research
in asset pricing basically find support
for both of these stories so in some
instances market work better the
frictionless models work better and
other instances there are severe market
frictions that lead to miss pricing in
markets finally as pair mentioned this
research is interesting because it has
not only influenced academics but also
practitioners in financial markets and
there are several examples of this but
let me make highlight one so the early
findings of Eugene fama that show that
it's very hard to predict how stock
prices are going to go do in the in the
short run that basically implied that
all these people who spend lots of
effort trying to guess which stock is
going to do better in which stock is
going to do worse that activity is you
know a very rather futile activity or
actually extremely difficult activity so
maybe instead we should just passively
invest in a large index because we can
do that much cheaper we don't need to
spend so much effort in trying to pick
stocks and that's exactly what happens
so the years after from us research
there was the emergence of this new type
of fund the index fund which invests in
the broad index a very passive strategy
at very low cost and this has helped you
know many many households throughout the
world to be able to invest in stock
markets much more cheaply than the
otherwise could have thank you okay
thank you so much professor strong
barrier we have got hold of all three
laureates we will now see if it can have
a professor she lived with us on the
phone are you there professor Saylor I
am ok good morning it should be around
seven o'clock so you've got a morning
coffee and we are right now in new haven
connecticut and i hand over a you know
i'm sitting here the session hall at the
royal swedish academy of sciences and
are you prepared for some questions yeah
I don't know if I'm prepare her I'm here
you're there ok here's one first one
first of all congratulations mr.
Schiller from the swedish television
thank you mrs. sheila what was your
reaction we're receiving the telephone
call from the Nobel Prize Committee
announcing the award I could just
believe that's the only way to put it so
was it expected in a way I'm sorry was
expected did you expect it the telephone
well I have I a lot of people have told
me they think they hoped I would win it
but I'm aware that there are so many
other worthy people that I had
discounted it so I would say no I did
not expect it so please mr. Schiller
tell us all the reasons for your
interest in this field of economic
theory well I've well I've interested in
a million different things I was
attracted to economic I think because it
deals with really important problems
it's a it's a rigorous discipline
finance drew me in because it's so
fundamental to human activity and it
follows precise mathematical relations
but there's an element of imprecision in
it that reflects human nature altogether
I founded a fascinating and important
field I know it's early in the morning
but
what does this price mean to you and
your profession well I oh yeah I believe
that for all speaking I'm trying to for
all three of us that finance is a theory
that while it has many controversial
elements also has a body of knowledge
that is useful for society and it will
help improve human welfare and I'm glad
to see that this has been given
recognition Thank You mr. Schiller okay
do we have some more questions here in
the room okay if not I yo here we have
one question please Thank You mr.
Schiller congratulations also Louise
under netten from Swedish de leus
svenska Dagbladet if you look at the
economic situation today that we're
having how would you describe that your
findings could be best used in today's
economic environment well I've written
books about this I have a book called
finance and the good society that came
out last year to read my book but I
would say that finance drives modern
civilization this may seem odd to some
people but it's absolutely true our best
activities have to be financed and I i
want to see finance developed further to
serve humankind sort of has finest then
after the financial crisis sort of ended
up when ours yeah as for the financial
crisis that reflected mistakes and
imperfections in our financial system
that we are already working on
correcting I think there's much more to
be done
I think it will take decades but we've
been through financial crises many times
in history and we've generally learned
from them so thank you okay yeah I look
around I think that was the lost
question and thank you again professor
Saylor and warmest congratulations and
we look forward to meet you here in
Stockholm in December for all the
celebrations Thank wonder her so let us
now move to to some more questions about
the prize in economic sciences are there
any additional questions you would like
to pose to the panel here okay if not a
i think i will close this press
conference and welcome you all to the
press events that we have in december
seven and eight you win the Nobel week
when all the lords in physics chemistry
and economic sciences will gather and
hold their prize lecture so well then is
see you then and thank you for your
attention